it is true that negative thinking can be
very addictive from my point of view it
is not caused by the chemical that's
generated in the brain or they do not
deny that the chemicals in the body very
often reflect certain things that happen
on the mental emotional level but what
comes first the chicken or the egg if
you become very angry of course there
are certain chemicals that are released
in the body and if you become peaceful
then they go the addiction is not in the
chemical other I don't deny that there
is a chemical component to emotional
states but it is the addiction to
negative thinking and the addiction to
negative thinking is usually connected
to the pain body which is the emotional
field that feels fed fueled by the
negative thinking hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I don't
always wake up and feel motivated to go
take on the day and the thing that sees
me that helps me every day is being
around people who are thinking bigger
who are changing the world and it gives
me a little more inspiration to go after
my mission and so I hope this video
helps you go up to yours today too so
today let's learn the secret blueprint
that can shift your reality Joy
meditation the actual translation of the
word meditation means to become familiar
with so the first thing you have to do
is you have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation rule number
two is create a vision board with John
azerath A lot of people ask me if I
still use a vision word like I showed in
the smash-up movie The Secret and the
answer is I do but it's slightly
different than the one I used to have
I am sitting here in Port and Drax in my
arc of Spain and
um this is a little bit of uh what's
been on my vision board in the last
several years if you take a look at this
area it's one of the most beautiful
little Paradise Islands anywhere in the
world surrounded by the Mediterranean
now why am i showing you that well
um this is my exceptional life blueprint
and in this exceptional life blueprint I
have pictures of my let me just move the
camera a little bit my wife my kids my
family
and I have pictures of things that I've
already achieved and you know homes that
we've either owned jets that we've flown
places that we vacation you know cars
that either I want to have or I want to
or that I do have and experiences that I
want to enjoy you know we rented this in
Maldives last year we have a home in
Colorado over here this was in Bali I'm
sorry in the South Pacific Islands of
Bora Laura we've rented
Yachts we've been in the most beautiful
places now why am I sharing this with
you you think I'm trying to impress you
and the answer is I'm not trying to
impress you I want to just show you
something I want to impress upon you
something
first you have to get a vision of what
it is you want to trade your life for
and it's not about the cars and the
houses and the and the and the trips
like what do you want to have your life
feel like
um what do you want to achieve in your
health wealth relationship career
business contribution charity Etc
the reason it's so critical to start off
with a vision even when you do not know
how to achieve it and you probably know
this I left high school at grade 11. I
was voted most likely to fail English
and math I failed in grade seven I
didn't think I was smart enough good
enough worthy enough
but I had a guy by the name of Alan
Brown my first Mentor when I was 19 that
asked me like what do you want to trade
your life for what would you like your
life to be like and he dared me to dream
and at the time I said well I love a
four bedroom house I'd love to get a job
that I'm making more than 1.65 an hour
which is what I was making in a shipping
Department of Philips electronics and
um I was doing a lot of stuff that I
shouldn't have been doing as a you know
as a teenager but he helped me create a
vision first even though it was a
fantasy it wasn't even a fantasy it
didn't even feel like it could be a
fantasy because I didn't have any idea
how to achieve it
and once I created my vision for health
wealth relationships career business
fund experiences travel
Etc he said to me um
what would you need to believe
in order to achieve these things
and I said well um I guess I would need
to believe that I'm smart enough he says
yes says what else would you need to
believe I said well I guess I would need
to believe that that it's possible he
says yes said what else would you need
to believe I said well I guess I would
need to believe that it's possible for
me and that I'm worthy of it and that I
deserve it and I went on to list all of
these beliefs can he help me with a few
beliefs like you know I would need to
believe and have the self-discipline and
then he went on to say well what would
your identity need to be like and I was
like identity what do you mean he says
well
everybody has character traits that
they're abiding by right now but in
order to achieve you know these big
goals that you have you'd have to have
some new character traits and and he
said things like self-confidence things
like certainty things like feeling
empowered things like feeling you can
overcome anything things like knowing
that you can learn anything to apply
what is needed to achieve those goals he
says in order to achieve the goals that
you have the vision that you wrote down
on this you know sheet of paper which he
gave me you have to create the identity
and the character traits to behave in
those ways you have to practice to make
those permanent in your mind so practice
is what makes permanent he says a lot of
people are practicing the wrong things
and they're making the wrong self-image
permanent the wrong identity permit the
wrong beliefs permanent the wrong habits
permanently says in order to achieve any
goal you want to achieve you have to
create the right patterns that drive the
right behaviors that achieve the results
you want rule number three is develop an
abundance mindset with Gabby Bernstein I
was brought up with a major lack
mentality I grew up in a very wealthy
town and my family really struggled
financially so that separation was real
there was a lot of concern a lot of
uncertainty
constant fear around finances
and I made a Quantum shift I decided to
have a Quantum shift I chose to adjust
my mentality around money early on
early on
and so much of it is what I'm going to
teach you today
really grounding myself in possibility
grounding myself in the truth that my
parents stories did not have to be mine
noticing that when I put hard work into
something that money was reciprocal that
I was receiving for what I was putting
out I was
19 years old and I started promoting
parties in New York City
and the first night that I promoted a
party everybody said Gabby at the door
and I got a percentage of the bar and
that night I walked out of that bar with
a thousand dollars cash
and I remember standing there in the
streets of New York City like holding my
cash close to my handbag and just like
clutching my bag and thinking wow I just
figured out how to make some money and
from that point forward
I made the decision
that I was going to seek abundance
rather than lack
and for me that was a Quantum shift not
everybody has a Quantum shift like that
but for me with money I had a Quantum
shift I made the decision in that moment
to choose abundance over lack
I believe that's available to you right
here right now listening to this show
there are all kinds of ways that we can
earn all kinds of creative possibilities
for earning
and when we open our hearts and our
minds and our willingness and our
courage to actually do work to show up
to be willing to to earn
and we start to shift our energy around
what's possible
we open up that creative mindset show me
creative possibilities for abundance we
stop limiting ourselves
and we get ourselves out of that
confined lack mentality
a lack mentality of there's not enough
to go around a lack mentality of oh well
so and so is already doing it how could
I a lack mentality of who could I be to
do this who am I to even want that
a lack mentality that might be really
ingrained in your upbringing belief
systems that you carry on
a lack mentality that's keeping you
small keeping you stuck keeping you from
possibility and opening our hearts to
what is possible begins with even that
simple prayer I'm open to creative
possibilities for abundance say that out
loud right now I'm open to creative
possibilities for abundance how does
that feel in your body say it again I'm
open to creative possibilities for
abundance what is that what is that
resonance in your energy
how does that feel
when you open your
mind and your conscious awareness to
more of what's possible
more of what's possible starts to be
presented to you
just starting even right here right now
with that prayer I'm open to creative
possibilities for abundance I want you
now to pay attention to the abundance
that is around you also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is Manifest your
dream with Grant Cardone I don't want to
share three things with you that I truly
believe in this manifestation thing now
I'm not that Voodoo
Law of Attraction guy I can tell you
images of pictures walking in on
something looking at looking at other
possibilities getting examples of other
people doing things is so so valuable I
mean it's our first way to learn is to
mimic is to see as babies are are you
know we see our parents
playing with their phones guess what we
want to pick up the phone and play with
the phone
we see our parents typing on a computer
the kids want to do what they want to
come type on your computer they don't
even know how to use it yet it's
mimicking it's basically taking
something else somebody has done boom
pot boat I want boat okay it's the way
we learn to cook you watch your mom cook
eggs or fry bacon or make oatmeal and
she's got her own recipe guess what
that's the recipe you use so we end up
with all these little twerks and weird
habits back in the 50s you know all our
parents smoked so what happened when the
kids grew up they picked up smoking and
alcohol Etc so the first thing to do is
on the manifestation thing is you got to
have some pictures right if you don't
have those pictures
you have poverty around you you have
struggle you have like I grew up in
struggle I didn't grow up in poverty I
grew up in a struggle even though we had
enough okay it was always this idea that
there wasn't enough even when there was
enough it was crazy even when we had
enough dude it was always this idea that
we didn't have enough and I keep moving
around just because I want you guys to
see these views they're just ridiculous
beautiful little town of Positano that
is filled with magic okay and for those
of you who've never traveled here or
been over this part of the world man
come over here figure out let me sit
down this is one of the things I do
first I take a lock in on a picture bang
yacht second thing I'm gonna do is try
to get as close to that thing the
manifestation thing not the Law of
Attraction but the law of action okay
first I see it then I'm gonna try to get
I'm gonna close the distance now it took
me 20 years to get on this this Beast
okay but what I could do in between then
and I hope it doesn't take you 20 years
is I've started collecting pictures and
images okay until I could actually put
my feet on
get as close as you can between you and
the target
if it's a boat a plane a business
business ownership an RV a car whatever
it is okay what you want to do is take
pictures of it collect images of it okay
maybe reinforce those by looking at them
often thinking about them just playing
with it don't even worry about how to
get it what it's going to take to get it
and the second thing is to start like
closing the distance between you and
that image could be pictures could be
images could be researched it could be
you going to the car dealership and
actually sitting in the car or you know
getting an appointment to go see the
house I remember
this is insane to think this but I
remember when I
did not think
that I could get somebody to show me a
house
I remember when I was like I was Elena
and I were in L.A I wanted to see this
house that was for sale and I was
concerned that they wouldn't think
enough of me to even let me see the
house
so if you guys have ever struggled with
all this limited thinking okay later I
bought the house I was literally bought
the house ended up making on that house
I made like 12 million dollars or
something
and I did not think when I went into the
house that I was going to be able to
even see the house
so if you suffer from a self-esteem
issue
are
sense of self or was telling my daughter
the other day I said man I've had
self-esteem issues my whole life not
thinking I was good enough not thinking
I could get there I'm still doing it
today
you know I started thinking about you
know last time I was here 20 years ago
one day I would be on a boat here in
Positano now I'm thinking one day I'm
gonna be here on my own boat
what do you want to be on okay so number
one okay take a picture of it too
close the distance in three at some
point you're going to have to start
doing the math and the math for me is
this what would it take to buy this
what is the resources the beans the
coins the dollars the energy the output
the number of people I need to make
contact with and if I can't figure that
out
just figure this simple math out how did
uh he do it how did
he do it how did he do it what business
are they in
what do they do to do this how did they
get it and maybe it's just a charter
okay so nothing wrong with that okay I
hope you guys do well hope you figure
out some things that really get rich in
your mind about your manifestations
about what you want what your purpose is
what's driving you to fuel you so you
can and your you and your family can
have a great life if you ever get to
post a tunnel
let me know rule number five is
eliminate negative thoughts with Eckhart
Tolle it is true that negative thinking
can be very addictive
I from my point of view it is not caused
by the chemical that's generated in the
brain although I do not deny
that the chemicals in the body very
often reflect certain things that happen
on the mental emotional level
but what comes first the chicken or the
egg
so if you
if you become very angry of course there
are certain chemicals that are released
in the body and if you become peaceful
then they go the addiction is not in the
chemical other I don't deny that there
is a chemical component to emotional
states
but it is the addiction to negative
thinking
and then the addiction to negative
thinking is usually connected to the
pain body which is the emotional field
that feels
fed fueled by the negative thinking so
if who do with addicts means it feels on
some level it feels good if you're
addicted to something on some level it
feels good if you're addicted to alcohol
the drinking feels good while you drink
not afterwards but while you drink
so if you're addicted well who
to whom does it feel good not to you
not to the physical body because the
physical body suffers
through it but to the pain body this
emotion loves to get more of the same
energy by generating further negative
thinking in your mind and it feeds on it
because it doesn't get enough food
through the drama in your relationship
so the awareness has to come in so that
you break the link
between
your pain body
and your thought processes
that is the key is to sever the link
between your thought processes and the
pain body in order to savor the link
between those
that needs to be enough awareness
presence only the presence can save her
the link the presence comes in and so
you you no longer
the emotion is no longer controlling
your thought activity
that's the key
and that's the beginning of the end
of that
vicious circle
that otherwise will take over your life
so
what is needed
is for you to be there in the moments
these thoughts occur or immediately
after and then immediately look at the
thought and say that's again and do not
believe it rule number six is practice
meditation with Jay Shetty I have taken
different practices from different
Traditions that I find fascinating
overall I follow a text called The Vedas
which is a universal text which doesn't
have a religion or particular spiritual
path aligned to it it's just speaking
universally about practices like
meditation and wisdom and knowledge and
so for me I practice three different
forms of meditation breath work
visualization and Mantra which is the
repetition of sacred sound a lot of what
I practice is inspired out of India
because that was the tradition I lived
in as a monk and so to me but but I
honestly having said that you know I've
Loved pretty much every spiritual text
I've picked up I I tell and read stories
from so many different Traditions I I
consider myself a practitioner you know
like a citizen of the world yeah when it
comes to culture and spirituality
because I feel like I can genuinely
learn from any part in any tradition and
rule number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is live in
the present moment with Michael
laysinger so the great spiritual path
which is also the great way of life
is to turn this back is to say life has
the right to be the way it is it's very
Grand of you I think right if life has
the right the moment in front of me has
the right to be the way it is there are
forces doesn't mean I like it doesn't
mean it's I can give lots of reasons why
would be better another way than change
anything I think it'd be neat if we
could fly so we didn't have to have
planes and we'd have to go through TSA
and guess it all takes so long right
come on guys grow up you start by
honoring and respecting reality so you
come into the moment and you do the work
you need to do to stop making up an
alternate reality and trying to impose
it on top of reality
know people get really scared with that
well how will I succeed I want to know
how you manage succeeding fighting with
everything or like I'm telling you 90 of
all of your shock to your Qi your energy
is wasted suppressing the stuff from the
past
using your mind to make up how you want
it to be make all those decisions that
are so important and then fighting with
everybody and everything and you're
using so much energy you have no idea
imagine if you have taken that golf shot
and during ask your golf pro but what
I'm going to do is every movement when I
move my arms back I'm going to think am
I doing it right maybe I should go
another degree and then I'll watch and
I'll see and I'll see what's right how's
that shot gonna be no one will tell you
did a shot like that it's supposed to be
a fluid free action period there's not
supposed to be any mind involved it is
supposed to be a complete merger of your
whole being and all of your energy into
the Oneness of hitting that ball go ask
anybody all right that's that's it
that's martial arts that's sports that's
everything
same way with life if you stop this
mishigas this craziness that we are
doing with our minds
and come into the present moment
and ask that moment what is the highest
we could do together that's what you've
asked the golf ball that's sitting on
the edge of the roof what is the highest
we can do together how can I join you in
the rough and participate in this moment
and bring the joy that can exist in this
moment and do the best that I can
because the best you can do is the best
that you can do in the moment it's not
something you made up hypothetically if
you live that way each moment will be
better in the next moment you will have
brought your best game to every single
moment you're doing that goes for
everything goes for business it goes
from relationships if you're in a
relationship and somebody comes to you
and says I I need to talk to you those
dreaded words I need when you come back
from work tonight that's really nice we
need to have a talk I I I've been
wanting meaning to talk to you for a
while but I've been scared but I I I'm
ready my therapist said I should talk to
you
okay all right so you're gonna have one
hell of a day aren't you you're gonna
your mind's gonna make up with you to
talk to you about like this that what
you're gonna say back this is gonna be
terrible and then you're gonna sit down
and by the time you did all that the
person's gonna sit down and start to
talk instead they're saying you know I'm
really sorry you know because I I
care for you it starts like that but
there are just some things that right
away out of your mouth because you've
decided what they're talking about right
it's not true I didn't do that I know
you think I always knew youth I thought
that you thought that I thought that you
did that but it's not true I didn't do
it George didn't he just lied to you wow
wow I jumped the gun a little bit here
you know what you're going to do you
want to protect yourself from something
you are not comfortable with and you're
going to try to use this conversation so
that you walk away feeling a little bit
better because you didn't feel
comfortable with it all day that's very
different then you're going to use this
conversation with this person you care
about has said I need some help with
something rather than bringing yourself
into the moment trying to see can I be
of some assistance you don't care about
what that person's going through you
care about what you're going through
because that person is threatening you
and therefore every word you say and
everything you hear and everything they
do will be about you it won't be about
them that's how it gets when the
emotions get involved isn't it it'll be
about protecting yourself well if you
protect yourself you're the worst
partner that ever lived if you come into
that moment let go of the part of you
that is your personal come into the
moment this is your friend this is your
partner and listen to what the person
has to say
literally listen maybe you'll hear
something maybe something can be
improved maybe it has nothing to do with
what you're thinking about anyways maybe
they want to tell you I just wanted to
tell you that I've always wanted to go
back to Ireland and I know you work hard
I bought the tickets
please don't be mad at me it's for our
anniversary
[Music]
I forget what I said about George
on your mission
that you're on what challenges with that
format that you've built
have you faced for what's next and
what's been the advantage of that format
for what you've been able to build and
the impact that you're making in the
world it's my biggest limitation is
still lack of belief
yeah so
people say well you're the believe guy
it's like yeah but I believe in myself
to do the things that I've done now but
to do the next the next big thing I
don't believe myself do to the next big
so I still need the channel for myself
because I want to wake up and have Oprah
Winfrey or Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or
whoever it is Whispering messages in my
ear to get me going to do the next thing
um one of my my uh you talk about the
format of of giving tribute to other
people at the beginning it was just hey
I've learned this from these people and
I think you might be able to learn too I
was just hoping to shortcut the path
because my my worst day in my first
business was when I said I quit on my
business partner
and I woke up the next day and said I
can't quit yet because I'm going to
regret this if I don't figure this out
at least at least if it doesn't work out
fine but at least know that I gave it
everything because I don't want to look
back and say I wish I just tried a
little bit harder
but I couldn't keep going the way that I
was going so I had to find another path
and the thing that came to me was I
can't be the first person to try to
solve this problem like somebody's
figured this out why don't I just model
success like that wasn't model success
it wasn't words that I would use you
know it was probably a lot more clumsy
but I can't be the first person to
figure this out somebody's done it and
that's where I studied Bill Gates it's
like Bill Gates had a like who's got a
software company I had a software
company so who's got a successful
software company Bill Gates came to mind
like this was not very Advanced planning
it's just top of Dome uh so okay how did
Microsoft get started and how did he
build like not so much how did how does
Bill Gates make an extra million dollars
now who cares but like zero to one how
do you do that and it was through
Partnerships and in learning how he
applied at Microsoft I brought that to
my business and quickly after I had my
first check for thirteen and a half
thousand dollars and that may not seem
like a lot but when you're making 300
bucks a month like 13 and a half K it's
like holy cow this is a grand slam here
and more importantly I could do that
again that was just one deal I could
close more deals so the idea the
strategy there was model success find
people who have done this and put that
the use in your business or your life
and so I I then went on this mission to
continue learning how I can model other
people's success and then I that
eventually became my YouTube channel
where I shared a lot of messages
um a surprising benefit of that has been
I've gotten to meet some of these people
you know like I was just profiling some
of them and then now I get to do
interviews with them or go hang out with
them or go to their houses and some of
them have become friends which was never
part of the idea of what I could do it's
just hey I love your message
I'm trying to get it out to the world
because if I learn from it maybe other
people like me can learn from it and
it's been amazing to be able to foster a
lot of those connections too in that
year when I was really broke and I was
really broken I was working at La
Unified School District
I was miserable
I was miserable because I wasn't living
in my dream I was just doing a j-o-b and
then one day I said well what what do I
need to do I I need to I need to buy my
freedom
that's what I need to do I need to buy
my freedom well I don't know about
buying my freedom I don't know about
buying I don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up my mother used to tell me oh
this money is burning my pocket so I
know two things about money is hot
and we can't keep it long
we'd always have one week where we had
all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty
right come on come on some of you guys
know about that to this day I spent so
much money on groceries you guys oh my
God it's like I'm feeding like a family
of 10. because I'm so afraid of anybody
ever being in my house and being hungry
right
and so I I wrote a check to myself
Jelani was three
hundred and ten dollars
took it to the bank
Wells Fargo
started a new account
the next check I wrote
125 dollars
and just like the first check I put in
the memo line funding my dream I wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but I knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for La
Unified School District and no
disrespect to La Unified School District
it just wasn't my destiny
I wrote another check in two weeks
146 dollars
funding my dream
now I started mailing the checks in
because I didn't want to see my balance
because I didn't want to go shopping
because I you're gonna repeat what you
learned right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned so I mailed
the check in and I wrote another check
and I wrote another check and every
check I wrote I made sure it was five
percent more than the first check the
net the previous check I sold my Altima
I had a car note sold my Optical bought
a clunker because it didn't have a car
note now I can write a bigger check
funding my dream
I moved out of my three bedroom three
bath three bath house and moved in
became a roommate with my friend who
smoked I put towels at the base of the
door so the smoke wouldn't come to the
door I was willing to be inconvenienced
are you yes yes I'm just saying I'm just
I'm just showing you the story I just
the charge I just gave you I stopped
getting my hair done that was when I
started going natural
I I stopped going out
I I stopped going out dancing I stopped
going out to dinners my family didn't
know what was going on they thought oh
my God you know it's La she's on drugs
but she's not losing weight so maybe not
I don't know what's going on
I kept writing bigger checks to myself
nine hundred dollars nine hundred
dollars
I mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream
eleven hundred dollars
mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream was
I just knew I had one
and it was being born through me
and I needed to give it a chance
that's all I knew
you don't have to see 2 000 feet in
front of you just see 200.
and run to the 200.
you'll have to see it all
three and a half years later I'd written
a check to myself every two weeks for
three and a half years
I didn't go out for three and a half
years I didn't go dancing I didn't get
my hair done I didn't get my nails done
for three and a half years are you
willing to be inconvenience for your
conviction
I walk in to Wells Fargo three and a
half years later
and I said hi God bless you hi
my name is Lisa Nichols she goes oh my
gosh you're the funding my dream lady I
was like
yeah I guess I am and all of a sudden
all the tellers came running around the
manager came they're like oh my God okay
oh my God we have been wondering we all
got the same question y'all know what
the question is right
what's your dream
I was like um
I'm not sure
but I know that it includes inspiring
people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
get having to be willing to give
themselves a thousand Second Chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
I'm not sure what it's going to look
like but it's just gonna help people
I said I came to check my balance I've
been writing a few checks to you guys to
say yes you've been writing a lot
I said I just want to check my balances
you don't know your balance I said no I
got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home because my mama
said money Burns her pockets and I don't
want it to burn my pocket I wanted to
pay for my freedom
I said I just came to see what my
balance was if I had enough to fund my
dream as it gets clear
she wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me I
looked at it I said oh no my name is
Lisa Shantae Nichols and my social
security number I said that is not my
money and I am not taking that money
because you're probably gonna want it
back
so just fix that error right now
and they looked at me
I said you really don't think that's
yours
I said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank or ten
thousand dollars in the bank
that's
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
in the bank
they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said Miss Nichols whatever your
dream is
I think you can fund it now
I looked at my son Jelani who now was
five or six and I said Jelani
our lives are going to be a little
different now baby
Jelani said yeah
Mommy can we
can't we now go to McDonald's
see for three years I've been telling
Jelani I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's
and so it began with a hundred and ten
dollar check
so I don't know what yours is I don't
know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right yes yes and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the bet the next
best step this is the first step and so
I just stopped by to let you know you're
on the right path
and as you ramp up as you ramp up you're
going to have questions you're going to
be afraid I do more things afraid now
than I do Fearless
because the bigger you play the bigger
your breakdown
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one every single one
of my errors has required me to call an
attorney
like they're just big because I'm
playing big
I'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here
be willing
to go to the edge
and not just lean over
and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump
and watch them soar and look through the
windows at all the people who are living
great life don't just go to the edge and
feel it
be willing to lean
fill your heartbeat feel it
that lets you know you're alive
to let you know you're okay
fear fuels you fear lets you know go get
more information fear let you know step
a little later and study fear lets you
know get up a little earlier fear let
you know ask for help fear is informing
you it's not stopping you it's just
another emotion like love and compassion
and gratitude we just made it paralyze
us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear I feel it and I'm moving
forward anyway I feel it and I'm gonna
love anyway I feel it and I'm going to
invest in me anyway I feel it and I'm
going to show up and play anyway when
you get connected with fear it becomes
your best friend and when you stand on
the edge
oh
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap anyway well what is Max out
really stand for for you and when did
that moment happen where you knew that
that was gonna be part of your brand
yeah
um my son's name is Max so that helped
um but maxed out to me means this as you
know your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll eventually possess
so if you're obsessed with what you're
worried about your fears your problems
you're going to possess those and so I
became obsessed
um the the short version is is that you
don't know this I don't talk about this
on camera very much when I was 30 my
uncle died at 50 years old and he was
the guy in my family we all have this
that you kind of resemble or remind
everybody of my dad's brother he died at
50. sorry no thank you I appreciate that
it's a long time ago now and but he was
kind of with my godfather and or my
culture that's a big deal of course
might as well yeah I know shout out
Uncle Mike yeah mine was Uncle Mike
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa everywhere
right there whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
Whoa man that's how the universe works
right
wow okay
you got me right there
so mine was my Uncle Mike
wow
and oh no man that just touched me
so
mine was my Uncle Mike and uh that blows
my mind right there brother
so
I'm on I'm at his funeral we're flying
back on the flight there's this thing in
your brain called the reticular
activating system it basically filters
into your awareness what's important to
you that's why like if you buy a new car
all of a sudden you see that car
everywhere on the freeway three lanes
over on the other side another one they
were always there why do you see them
now it's filtered into your importance
and heart attacks were at my he had died
of a heart attack and so I'm on the
airplane and I'm listening to music and
on the screens the Oprah show but I'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart on
the screen I'm like
unplug my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at Cedar
Sinai where they could like it's common
now but they could non-invasively look
at your heart and your arteries
long story short I hear it and I told my
wife I said schedule me for one of those
exams she's like it's expensive I don't
care schedule it we call it's a nine
month wait I go I need to get in I need
to get in I keep calling the lady
finally she goes there's a cancellation
tomorrow at two I go I'll be there so I
go down for the scan and thank God this
doctor understood influence and leverage
do you do the scan then you come back
after lunch I literally went ate a
burrito
came back I wasn't in shape I'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
no I'm looking for Edward mylet I go
it's mylette you know and he goes uh he
knew and he goes
well I can't believe these arteries are
in that younger body wow you need to
come back son
now my heart's racing I'm like what the
hell's in the skin we sit down instead
of what a normal doctor would do they
just go hey um here's the prescription
take Crest or work out eat goodbye he
understood reasons is what changes
people's lives massive reasons not
disciplined reasons and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful
um
uh do you have kids I go yeah I go I got
a son he's one he goes That's great um
do you want to be there when he
graduates high school
I went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school I
said uh yeah he goes okay uh yeah she's
pregnant I go yeah what does she have
and I said a girl you get to a dad this
is what you say he goes would you like
to walk that little girl down the aisle
on her wedding day son
I went what what is in this scan dude
and he goes I want to be very clear with
you young man I remember this like
yesterday because I want to be very
clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man's going to live with
your beautiful wife in your mansion walk
your son at graduation and he's going to
be arm in arm with your daughter on her
wedding day not you you'll be alone
actually as I tell you this right now
dude right and he goes what I'm going to
get you to do is I'm going to get you to
max out your life and your Fitness
and I went
get me yeah and he gave me exactly what
I needed to do and he said if you do
this you'll walk her down the aisle blah
blah blah from that day when I get up
like I did this morning and I'm tired
and I was late last night and I don't
want to go to the gym I swear to you
brother I swear to you I go Bella's
wedding get your ass up and I go I I'm
fit because I have massive reasons
that's why I'm fit and that started the
journey towards maxing out every area of
my life I'm like if I can do this in my
fitness I can do this in business I can
do this in my spirituality and
everything I'm not going to shortchange
myself by pretty good I'm going to see
what my real potential is what my
maximum capacity is every single day
because at the end of my life when I do
die I have this belief that when I'm
done the Lord's going to go well done
good and faithful servant and by the way
here's the man you could have been this
is the man you were born to be this is
the man you were destined to be this is
where you could have gone but you could
have seen the memories you could have
had the people you could have helped the
person you could have become and meet
him my obsession is that every day I'm
chasing that dude so that when I do die
we meet we're identical twins because
the bad end of a life whether it would
be at 30 50 or 150 would be I meet that
guy and we're total strangers yeah so
I'm obsessed with meeting that guy
someday and that's what maxing out means
it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that you know is the
reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's starting to exercise
or eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well same
thing is true with our brain and the
neural networks and pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you are taking to
achieve the results that you want more
and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they're comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your Knowledge and Skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the unwritten rules of Life check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there so first let's start
with a high five like think about when
in your life you have either given or
received high fives what does a high
five from someone else or a high five
that you're giving to somebody else
communicate you're on the same team